if you work on or around the strip you
have surely noticed all the traffic
problems recently you can see them right
there with the slogo las vegas boulevard
near sahara avenue now reduced to one
lane in each direction madison kimbrough
live from that area madison we wish we
could fly to work we got to grind
through it to get to channel 8.
that would be a great idea i wish we
could do that too yeah frustration among
drivers again this week right here on
las vegas boulevard and sahara take a
look behind me where you can see traffic
is busy but it is moving pretty swiftly
here now frustration again and take a
look as i said there are 24-hour lane
closures as construction crews work in
this area through tomorrow night at six
now while traffic is restricted to one
lane in each direction in the block
south of sahara avenue the main entrance
for the sahara hotel is temporarily
closed so that's why you have to use
paradise for access the lane
restrictions are for replacement of the
asphalt pavement which we all have been
looking for and stripping on the
northbound side of las vegas boulevard
the lane closures are part of a
construction project that will continue
to affect las vegas boulevard from
spring mountain road to sahara avenue
through the fall
this project is the first phase of a
multi-year project on the boulevard
between sahara and the 215 beltway each
phase includes water line replacement
new pavement like we mentioned
intersection modifications to improve
pedestrian crossings upgrades to traffic
signals as well as led street lighting
systems with smart poles and enhanced
median landscaping there's a lot going
on the next phase of construction is
currently underway now between russell
and the 215. now there are some
alternate routes to take to avoid
getting stuck you can take sammy davis
junior drive to either circus circus
drive there's resorts world or genting
boulevard use paradise road and desert
inn and then also there are these great
traffic apps you can use that will
suggest alternate routes for you to
travel in reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now